so this is the time of year where we're  all thinking about our new year's  resolution so i wanted to plant an idea  in your head you might want to think  about going plant-based or vegan in  2022. it is the  morally  and ethically appropriate response to a  world disconnected with our innate  humanity it's also the best way to live  more sustainably to  take a stand on climate change by eating  a diet that is less  contributory to all of the detrimental  impacts that food systems have on  planetary health i've been vegan for  over 15 years at this point it is not a  deprivation lifestyle i think it is just  a fantastic and beautiful way of living  and i'm thriving i've been doing it for  a long time i know so many people i have  and so